la 17e étape du tour de france entre
fribourg en suisse et colmar en alsace
avant de rejoindre patrick chêne nous
nous rendons à strasbourg une ville qui
a indiscutablement une longueur d'avancé
en matière de deux roues une entreprise
de réinsertion cyclo coeur vient de
lancer une initiative intéressante
le vélo taxi que nous font découvrir
jérôme soûlard et sylvain gauthier non
cette année le tour de france ne passe
pas à strasbourg
mais dans la capitale alsacienne avec
150 km de pistes cyclables et déjà plus
de 10 % des déplacements urbains
bicyclette
la fête du vélo s'est un peu tous les
jours deux roues pour se déplacer trois
roues pour découvrir sans effort c'est
l'idée de cycle au coeur une entreprise
de réinsertion qui veut réinventer une
ville plus humaine
cox et jean sont installés aux commandes
du vélo et qu'ils ont derrière eux des
touristes
il y a une conversation qui s'engagent
et pour ceux qui disent que nous
véhiculons l'image de pays du
tiers-monde
vive les pays du tiers-monde si on doit
remettre un emploi à chaque français et
chaque citoyen de cette ville et de ce
pays et le public lui n'hésite pas une
seconde à se faire rouler deux
kilomètres de parcours idyllique une
vingtaine de kilomètres par jour pour
antoine l'un des trois cycles guide déjà
embauché et pour les touristes une
balade inoubliable au coeur du vieux
strasbourg
oui très remontés connaissent ma d'heure
c'est sympathique on voit tout on peut
s'arrêter ou anvers et c'est bien c'est
vraiment rouler regardez vous arrêter on
n'est jamais fatigué je pense que c'est
vraiment une super idée ça depuis
longtemps
ben ça fait cinq ans démoulez en béton
aujourd'hui je pense mais son confort
comparé à celui du petit train cyclo
coeur il ya déjà pensé dans son garage
associatif l'entreprise a déjà inventé
le vélo de l'an 2000 plus rapide et
moins fatiguant ou voulant tout
simplement ajouté le côté électrique qui
va permettre un plus à celui qui va être
aux commandes du vélo strasbourg ville
pilote a décidément des petits vélos
plein la tête
car au centre ville c'est sur la
bicyclette c'est écologique pratique et
en plus aujourd'hui ces mêmes reposant